I hate that no one tells you what
Epstein was actually doing with the
Cabba. Like, it's so obvious, but no
one's going to say it out loud.
Everything you own, from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says,
"You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves." Brothers
and sisters, Masid Norway, the one that
we built, is looking to another masid
around the area of Norway, Subhan Allah,
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This masid
is only $500,000. And any donation that
you give will go towards your because
when you enter that grave, nobody's
going to remember you except Allah
subhana wa tala. So make it count,
brothers and sisters, and donate towards
this message, inshallah, a new project
that's only $500,000. And believe me, if
every single one of us give £1,10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
To brothers and sisters, dear friends,
in this video, we're going to be
dissecting a few things. Number one, the
Caba piece, the piece of the cloth of
the Caba with the Quran ay that was sent
to Apin uh a known uh pedophile that was
working with Mossad had an island to
blackmail people of power to use it
against them which Mossad is known and
good at. That's number one. Number two,
we're going to understand why this
woman, this Saudi woman sent this cloth
to Epstein. Number three, we're going to
understand Kabala. Thanks to our brother
EQ, I don't need to do the work.
Alhamdulillah. Uh he is inshallah going
to be dissecting to us. So, we're going
to be watching a few videos. Uh we're
going to be reacting some articles and
we're going to be watching a video of a
Jewish uh person and individual who is
telling you why you should be very
careful using Kabala. Kabala is their
kind of good magic/ can be back bad
magic. Let's get straight into inshallah
through the video of EQ and see what he
had to say. I hate that no one tells you
what Epstein was actually doing with the
Caba. Like it's so obvious but no one's
going to say it out loud. This devil was
given pieces of the Cabba that contains
Quranic ayas on it. And it's for a
simple reason that you would never have
guessed. This is a part of a Cabala
ritual. Cabala is an ancient form of
Jewish magic that combines scripture and
the occult. Allah tells us in surah
bakar about two angels who were sent to
teach the Jewish people powerful verses
at the time of Babylon. But they took
those verses and used it in the occult.
When a person performs sahar, the shy
require a personal item that the devils
will use to link and write up their
contracts. So it could be fabric, a
personal object, hair. The idea is if I
have something from you, I can reach
you. But then you start realizing that
it's deeper than seah. This is what you
call a desecration ritual. It's
basically when you take something pure
and holy and you pollute it by doing
nasty things with it. Theiswah is
symbolic to the Muslim faith and it's on
the holiest of objects with Quranic
verses stitched in it. It makes you
wonder why would a devil like him even
have it. That's why some of the
strongest sah involves the desecration
of holy objects. For all we know, he
could have been using it to wipe his and
doing other nasty things with it to
appease his shy. But the bigger question
I want you to ask yourself is why did
Saudi Arabia gift it to him in the first
place?
>> Okay, good. So, brother uh Esq has
explained Kabala to a certain extent.
Alhamdulillah. There's uh more to it
which we're going to dissect. Uh
however, before we go to the Jewish man
who will come and explain why Kabala can
be used in the wrong way and it is used
by evil rabbis. Okay. So it's clearly
you can see uh from what we can see that
in Judaism it can be used for the good
or it can use be for the bad. Uh number
one. Number two. Now what brotherq said
is why did the Saudis send or a Saudi
resident or individual send this to him.
Now obviously maybe brother SQ didn't
know and of course these things can
happen. So yeah so brotherq may have not
known but let's go to the article of why
this was actually done. So what from
what I know it's that Epstein you as you
know they always uh you know these are
always working towards something to
cause destruction on earth and disorder.
That's what they're known for.
Everything that happens, most crime,
everything, atrocities around the world,
wars, etc. goes back to these scums of
the earth. They are Satan. Literal
Satan. Okay. So, this is what it is in
to give some clarifications that the
sister involved was absolutely innocent.
And here is why. Epson files uh show
Kabak piece from Mecca shipped him via
UAE linked contacts. Okay. So now sacred
cloth that covers shrine in Saudi Arabia
reached the convicted pedophile through
uh through United Arab Emirate links
businesswoman. Okay. So newly released
files include emails of detailing a
shipment of sacred cloth from the Ka in
Mecca to the United States arranged
through contacts linked to the United
Arab Emirates and delivered to convicted
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein. The
correspondence dated February and March
2000 shows UAE based businesswoman Aziza
Al Ahmedi working with a man named
Abdullah Al Mari to organize the
shipment of three pieces connected to
Kiswa, the black gold embroidered cloth
that covers the Ka at the center of
Islam's holy sites in Saudi Arabia. The
kiswa carries deep religious meaning for
Muslims worldwide. Each year the cloth
is removed from the shrine and replaced
with a new one with parts of the
previous kiswa treated as a highly
valuable artifact artifact. Emails in
the Epstein file show that the items
shipped by airfried from Saudi Arabia to
Florida via British Airways with
coordination spanning invoices, customs
arrangements and delivery inside the
United States. Now it does seem a bit
bizarre uh even though there is nothing
to say that the sister sent it on
purpose for him to use it for his filthy
disgusting whatever he was doing.
However, we will come to So the message
describes the three separate pieces, one
from inside the ka, one from the outer
cons uh covering that was used and the
third made from the same material but
not used. The correspondent describes
the unusual piece as a way to classify
the shipment under artworks. The
shipment arrived at Epson's home in
March 2017, long after he had served
jail time and registered as a sex
offender. In one email, Ahmedi under
underscored the cloth's religious
significance while addressing Epstein
directly. The black piece was touched by
minimum 10 million Muslims of different
denominations, Sunni Shia and others.
They walk around the cabba seven rounds.
Then everyone tries as much as they can
to touch it and they keep their prayers,
wishes, tears and hopes in on this piece
hoping after that all the prayers to be
accepted. She she added the
correspondence does not explain how
Ahmedi came to know or why the peace was
sent to him. So from what information
that I gathered is that he was trying to
make a bitcoin called I think called
Sharia or something like that. Okay. So
he had different alternatives and I
think he this was a businesswoman who
was doing that. There's no evidence to
to think otherwise. It was a
businesswoman who was trying to do
something something like I said a
bitcoin electronic. I think she owns a
gaming or technological company or
something like that. So they were going
to do something with Epson cuz he's got
a multi-billion pound billion pound
billionaire with we have no idea how he
got those money. Mosad of course. So she
was basically trying to do business with
him and I think as a kind gesture
whatever it is for that matter not
knowing what kind of a scumbag dirt back
and he's a Mossad agent Zionist satanic
devil worshiping um idiot dirt back he
is so she sent this to him in a show of
you know whatever is for that matter now
it does look a bit shady it looks a bit
like out of everything you want to say I
mean you could have sent anything you
could say send a sent a Quran you could
have sent um a little gift you can send
a perfume whatever it is It does seem a
little bit shady but we as Muslims have
to assume the best. So that is that. Now
going to the video of this man which I
want to watch show you guys inshallah
and you can see um subhan Allah that
they use kabala. Kabala is something
that Allahh sent from the mistaken from
the angels to Babylon. Okay. And warn
them that this is a test from Allah
subhanaa tala and do not use it for the
well do not use it for I don't know if
they was allowed to use it for the right
reasons or wrong reasons like the Jewish
this Jewish man is going to explain but
we can watch now in see the dark side of
Kabala. I heard conversations of people
who claims to teach cabala very foreign,
very dark, very awful methods and only
desiring false methods of the dark
secrets and and the names coalistic
codes and numeral values. It's like dark
and spooky and and and evil and very
bad. Very bad. When you see people with
anger, people that are claiming,
demanding, forcing, stay away from from
these kind of teachings. This is a fire
that is not meant to to be spread out.
This is foolishness. This is evil.
>> So, Subhan, as you can see, so this is a
Jewish man who's saying that Kabala can
be used for the wrong reasons. And we
said like in the Quran, Allahh mentioned
this. And look at the truth. Like how
does Allah know? Like in the Quran we
know Allah knows but how could it be
that God almighty if Islam is not true
how does it know all these things these
truths that are coming out Kabala is
being used brother and sisters to you
know not hack but gain information like
Allah says in the Quran that the gins
and the try to go to the certain heavens
and try to get information and they get
pelted by stones and they only get some
information and that's why we know when
was told that subhan allah there's going
to be a trial from ben is that's going
to cause the end of him So we know that
they had some kind of knowledge that was
given to them with with Allah's
permission of course um you know for
reason Allah is all knowing subhan Allah
but you can see subhan Allah the dangers
of that so the question is it is shady
it does look a bit weird to send a a
cloth like that who's been on the which
has been on the ka to a dirt back like
him she may not know but howful people
like that it's it's it's very strange
but it does show it's not that that it
was a request from him it may have been
there might be emails coming out but for
now the sister involved
Um there is no evidence to speculate
that she did it on purpose or
intentionally for them to desecrate and
use it for god knows what powers they
use it for. So that's why we should not
uh conflate uh you know Judaism. There
are bad and good Jews and you know
Zionists you can see they will do
anything for power and the whole world
is waking up to their reality.
Alhamdulillah. Candice Owens,
alhamdulillah, they're all waking up to
how evil these people are. And subhan
Allah, they using Kabala these methods
to and and this is what I believe them
what they did in Gaza was a mass
sacrifice. It was a mass sacrifice to
the jin andl to get powers and they will
do anything and Allah is going to
destroy their plots. Yes, they plan and
plot and Allah plans and Allah is the
best of planners and that's why you can
see the whole world has waken up to
their reality. So, alhamdulillah I want
to thank brother SQ for breaking that
down in explaining to us what the cabala
is inah and also the clarification of
why this was sent to Epstein and subhan
Allah Alen Mask Tommy Robinson and the
rest have gone silent. I will be
discussing this issue on the Da Bros
podcast with brother Dill Hussein going
in detail inshallah with our new uh
YouTube channel the Dow Bros podcast.
You can watch debates uh between Muslims
and others inshallah on our new set. We
don't need Pierers Morgan and we don't
need PBD anymore. We have our own show,
our own set where they will come and
debate our people inshallah. And keep an
eye on that channel. Till next time,
everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says.
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway, Subhan Allah, where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters, and donate towards this
message, inshallah, a new project that's
only $500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give one pound,
£10,100, £1,000, that's going to be
something you will never regret on your
makama. And everything that you lose is
going to perish and go. But your deeds
and your makyama are not. Donate to the
link inshallah. Let's get to the video.